in our series vaccinating america there
is concern that some of the most
vulnerable americans
are now being left behind in vaccination
efforts we are talking about people who
are unable to leave their homes
more than 1100 members of the texas
national guard were recently deployed
to help vaccinate people who are either
too old or just too ill to get around
nikki bates shows us how a non-profit
home visit nurse program
in new jersey is also trying to reach
homebound people who are not yet
vaccinated
good morning to you nikki this sounds
really interesting
gail good morning it's an important
story because so far the new jersey
health department
has not allocated a single vaccine
specifically for the homebound
that's why the visiting nurse
association here just began
a pilot program using vaccines given to
them
by community health centers our cameras
followed one of their nurses
driving doses door to door i'm carrying
something that's so valuable so yeah i'm
gonna watch every little thing i do with
it
packing up vaccines in a temperature
control cooler
don't jiggle it don't shake it it's like
liquid gold you're carrying this it's
you know let's hope that this change is
a crazy world we're in nurse peggy lasso
hits the seaside roads of new jersey
making a special kind of house call what
was i getting
a mcdonald's she's administering first
doses of covet-19 vaccines to homebound
patients
the elderly and those suffering from
medical conditions who can't get to a
vaccine site
we joined lassov as she went to them
house by house
for hours last off is a crucial part of
a pilot phase the new jersey visiting
nurse association health group has
launched which could become a framework
for the nation
i'm peggy they're very appreciative
they've been nervous and scared because
they
obviously can't get out to get it the
long-time nurse gave 79-year-old vincent
newland his
first covit 19 vaccine he has
heart disease lung disease kidney
disease
and multiple myeloma so he has a lot
going on
his daughter tyan told us her dad's dose
came after an unexpected phone call
they called us and said that they were
starting a pilot program
and if he would be interested in getting
it if they did
it was just like yeah like you want to
do it now they're kind of living in the
shadows they're easy to forget about
but they're our parents there are elders
and they need our help dr steve landers
leads the health group
he and his nurses treat ten thousand
people in new jersey on any given day
the states have not prioritized giving
the home health agencies themselves
vaccine products so there's you know
there's over 12 000
home health agencies across the country
and they serve these millions of
homebound people
i see constituents every day who are in
their 70s 80s 90s
who can't get vaccines new jersey state
senator vinco powell says his office has
received
countless calls from the homebound so he
contacted
new jersey governor phil murphy i've
raised it directly with him that we need
to move away from this open portal
system
this needs to be done in a more targeted
approach what was governor murphy's
reaction in general did he seem to
understand
we'll look into it and we'll get back to
you what do you say to state officials
who seem to have the power to expedite
this process
i've been speaking to everybody i can
about the importance of focusing on the
homebound
i think that the message is getting
through i didn't even feel it happening
that's a good thing dr lander says this
effort is not only about their patients
living but having a reason to maybe they
can feel more safe with their family
coming over and giving them a hug
a lot of power and a hug you have to
survive the virus
but you also have to have a reason to
live in family connections and joy
and and love and care
in a joint statement governor murphy's
office and the new jersey department of
health
told us that as vaccine supply increases
mobile options to reach vulnerable
populations will be incorporated
the statement also said the state has
had initial conversations with the
visiting nurse association
about prioritizing the homebound anthony
thank you nikki it's so disappointing
that that these home health agencies
have not been prioritized it's hard to
understand why what
nurse peggy lasso is doing there is so
important
i call that angels on earth yeah exactly
they said get in their car
go to people's homes door to door to
help you talk about door-to-door
service i think nikki bates said it very
well there's a lot of power in a hug
vaccine gives you some of that one-step
reality
getting closer to a hug i think it's so
important